الان الى ملف العلاقات الفرنسيه الافريقيه
حيث قال رئيس وزراء مالي كوكا ان
الفرنسيين قرروا مغادره بلاده بعد مجيء
حكومه لا تروق لهم على حد تعبيره واضاف في
مقابله مع الجزيره ان لدى بلاده معلومات
وادله على ان بعض الارهابيين الذين كانت
الدوله تحاربهم كانوا على تواصل مع باريس
مشيرا الى ان تعاون فرنسا العسكري مع ماله
لم يحقق ايا من اهدافه المتفق عليها
اود التاكيد على اننا لم نتخلى عن التعاون
مع فرنسا ولكنهم ارادوا ان يفرضوا علينا
ما نقوم به وما نعتقده ونحن نقول لهم ان
هذا العصر قد ولى فنحن نختار الشركاءنا
ونختار ما نقوم به الفرنسيون قرروا ان
يغادروا بعد مجيء حكومه لا تروق لهم
وكانوا يعتقدون اننا سنتوسل اليهم كي
يبقوا
لم يهزم الارهاب ولم تبسط سياده الدوله
ولم تطبق قرارات الامم المتحده خلال
الوجود الفرنسي هذا من جهه ومن جهه اخرى
لدينا معلومات دقيقه وادله ان بعض
الارهابيين كانوا على تواصل مع فرنسا